it is 11:32 p.m. on a Monday and you
know what a time it is it's time for
tired Tuesday okay so for this week's
tired Tuesday we're actually gonna be
analyzing college tuition and what's
kind of cool about this data set or data
sets is it contains a lot of different
information and for me I think I'm gonna
focusing I'm gonna be focusing more on I
guess the cost of tuition and it's like
ROI and my measure and ROI is like you
know your expected salary after
graduating so when we're looking over
this data dictionary we kind of have a
tuition cost CSV which has that the
universities name type of university
degree length it's also interesting
Kylie has a Reuben board tuition while
also having insane out-of-state tuition
where I was staying in sayers like the
sum of room and board plus in-state so
pretty easy math right there
additionally you also have tuition
income which has like the name the total
I guess price in USD and also like the
net cost so that's kind of an
interesting where it's like net cost of
average actually paid after the
scholarship award okay
additionally we have I think is what's
the most interesting part of this data
set or data sets is that it has like a
ranking of the school with also early
career pay and mid-career pay which
really make career pay is is definitely
the most interesting and I think it's
probably the most useful metric when
you're gonna go into a certain field
it's one thing to look at you're like
starting median salary out on college
but it's another thing to look at your
like five-year growth if you're once
you're in the field which is definitely
more important I want to say more
important but it's definitely a factor
that people should be including into
their own career plans additionally they
have some funny little like make the
world better percent whereas I presume
alumni who think they're making the
world a better place so that's pretty
kind of that's kind of cool to be like
really positive and they also have like
a stem percent of words like percent of
student body and stem
additionally they have like historical
tuition and like diversity along school
so it's like I guess racial racial and
gender diversity so I'm probably not
gonna focus a lot on diversity in school
however I will be kind of looking at the
historical tuition because I mean that's
just begging for a time series chart so
we'll probably mess with that a little
bit okay so we're gonna open up this
I'll put up some markdown all load in
tidy verse loaded in the data sets and
I'll rename this to tidy Tuesday oops
university tuition okay okay okay
sorry about that I had to rearrange some
windows so we have our data sets read in
and we're gonna I just I guess we'll
look at historical tuition first I think
we'll just ggplot it right right out of
the gate you know x equals y or y equals
tuition cost we'll just do a smoothing
line plus gym point something easy okay
we're getting something weird I bet we
can do just too much variance so let's
say uh yeah let's do color equals okay
it's not doing that okay let's go back
and I want to just look at it so maybe
we'll do a color equals tuition type
yeah okay
and then maybe I'll do group equals
tuition oops
to wish and type there we go
and it's a mess okay man maybe I should
just do a we're all thinking maybe I
should just go back to type because if
you type okay oops
type two okay so now we're comparing all
institutions private and public where
private tuition has definitely been
increasing like as a whole it's just
always more expensive that's kind of
expected I would say so nothing too
crazy but I think one thing that'd be
kind of interesting is historical
tuition group I typed summarize equals
men equals men tuition cost max equals
max tuition cost I spelled that wrong
oops okay and what just do like a
ungroup mute a range equals max minus
min okay and you really can't see how
it's like man the min max of tuition
costs are pretty huge right like for all
institutions like 23k difference whereas
privates 34 and punky 16 K it's kind of
an interesting thing but it's also
pretty sad but we're just going to use I
think we're just used to what tuition
cost yeah tuition cost and then we'll do
uh probably I want say we might not even
use tuition income to be honest because
I'm a little confused
total price and net cost so total price
is like total price of tuition I guess
plus but then they factored in
scholarships I'm not sure if we should
really include
our ships into this analysis because
those are kind of all over the place and
the main idea for this analysis is what
actually want to do is like what's the
what the universe has the best ROI and
maybe you could say our la ROI will
factor I'm like scholarships me with
maybe sports might have has some effect
where like if you're rolling in sports
you might want to consider going to a
place as a nice ROI with their net cost
over the actual like I don't gross cost
but I'm kind of thinking that we should
just stick with total costs like
in-state and out-of-state and we'll use
those that's kind of like different
metrics so and we'll just let's see here
what's your yeah we'll just do like a
left join I guess we'll do ones on on
its overall career so left joined by
equals name that should do something
right boom we got that mid-career pay I
guess we have a interesting so some of
it some of the data we don't actually
have a I guess early career pram a
creepy mid-career pay so we we kind of
need those things so I'm not gonna drop
those n A's and boom okay we have 670
schools where we have all this collected
data so I'm gonna say College yeah boom
okay so what's just like analyze and
let's first get some summary statistics
and I'm gonna do it you know really I
think not out the best way but we'll
just say like actually okay I got idea
I'm gonna do a select state and then was
it one two three four five six okay
we'll just say - name - state code -
type - degree length just agree
like what else do they have here
if I want those stuff okay what the and
then oh and then everything oh god I
gotta do this thing it's everything and
then I think we'll do you suck that
that's how it works right yeah there we
go got that a little bust up and then
we'll do a gather right gather key
equals key the classic you know data
manipulation thing - stay we got those
guys then we'll do a group I stay key
summarize and then what's - and we'll do
a medium and we'll do a deal men equals
men value median equals median value
average equals mean value and then we'll
say max equals max value median where's
median edge you have to promote that -
interesting okay I'll have to say mutate
how it goes as that numeric value I
should do it right yeah there we go uh
state name it oh okay I guess I - state
state state name rope okay
okay and I will do a pivot oh god watch
what I do is and then we'll just like
what do I want to really extract right
that's kind of the main idea oh I guess
we don't need to rank either - rank yeah
okay so we had the main meeting average
and max out of all these Valerie's for
each state so I am going to group by
state and we'll say what's and then
group will still keep that group I say
and key well let's say top and and we'll
say median who has a top meeting of all
these things right it's gonna be mostly
value but we'll say median and into N
equals 5
oh we don't need key actually if we just
say okay so Alabama this state has the
best make world better percent
interesting actually I got a better idea
we're just gonna we're gonna yeah we're
gonna top n it and median we have 46 uh
yeah we're just gonna GD plot it a s x
equals a state y equals median plus geom
column plus facet wrap key scales equals
3 okay and I sure did the car color
Ecola State Philly cool state okay
and I will me and actually we know we
don't need it plus a core flip because
it's a tie Tuesday and we probably don't
need the legend either because our
legend is based our x-axis and so we
don't really need it that position
equals no okay so top early career pay
between California and New York
Massachusetts kind of make sense room
and board
California is pretty expensive to live
there too one thing that's kind of
things like oh wow like New York
Massachusetts in California I feel like
those are definitely the the college
states that you always think of that
fork American universities so that's
kind of interesting okay so we kind of
did an EDA it wasn't a great da but what
my main idea behind this thing was I
want to create a model and it's kind of
like the lost hockey model but I want to
make a model that'll basically predict
um the total cost of a university and
basically try to figure out what are the
the what what colleges had the most ROI
and the way to drill measure this is I
couldn't make my own metric of like
dividing like a career pay by its
tuition and stuff like that but one idea
I was thinking ah and we'll do that but
one idea I was thinking was oh how about
we just use all these like metrics like
career pay make career pay the state and
try to predict like total cost and see
which ones are basically undervalued
given to our model so like our model
would expect it to be like $30,000 when
in reality it's only $10,000 which makes
it pretty pretty cheap consider what our
model would believe it should be but
first we're gonna do that ratio thing
that was first talking about just do
like a basic EDA so we're gonna select
in in-state tuition out-of-state tuition
and we'll say early career pay
mid-career pay okay and how we can do
this right
I got a I'm going to do another gather
gather key equals key value equals value
and my in-state tuition and - out of
state - total well out of state
oh I've earned it in state total - my
eyes I'll keep it fair okay right and
then we'll say the mutate in state and
then value is early career pay and
actually
trying to think how I should do this
let's see if I can gather scanner key
equals key to value equals value to
minus key - value and that ggplot a yes
x equals value y equals value to plus G
ohm point plus facet wrap what key plus
key to scales equals free that work yeah
that works ok ok
so it's comparing early career prey with
in state total early career pay with
out-of-state total it's stuff like that
one thing that's interesting we can do a
genome smooth and make sure does that
work it kind of works ok ok so we're
kind of comparing both in-state and
out-of-state with early and mid career
pay and one thing I was saying oh maybe
I should make it fixed that should be
interesting there we go we kind of tell
a better story because it's like your
early career pays right there and then
your mid career pays right here and to
be honest we could we could just ignore
this and you just kind of make it so
it's like whoo look I kind of want to do
that actually and then color oops
maybe it's key to and then color equals
key there we go all right we don't even
need to do this yeah right so that's
this is much a little bit more
interesting right we kind of have our
early career pay for our in-state total
you can see the variance
and then you have out-of-state and then
you have out-of-state I mean and then
you have your mid-career pay and you can
see how like kind of out of state is is
a little bit more spread to the right
meaning our sake total you're gonna
generate a little bit more in your
mid-career pay then your in-state total
but also in state and I'll estate total
for the early career kind of scene is
pretty much the same interesting we're
gonna we're going to do some summary
statistics too I mean we can't do that
without doing it so and then we'll just
do you know the try entry summary and we
can look at it min 87 1097
10 boom boom
so yeah very interesting
I really like this plot I'm not gonna
lie I'm not trying to do my own horn but
that is a cool-looking plot you can see
like the transition from early to mid
career pay I like on average yeah you're
gonna make more in your big career like
you should be making more there is some
slight overlap without a state I'll just
like to but San without Sun right I'm
pretty interesting stuff I kind of wish
I could make it so it's like one to one
but yeah I don't really want to worry
about that too much it's not that big a
deal okay so now we're actually going to
start creating is model um and we're
trying to we're kind of have to we're
gonna have to think about how we're
going to do this right so I kind of
don't want to factor in both
out-of-state tuition and in-state
tuition total but we we do want one of
the totals so we'll say select -
in-state tuition and - out-of-state
tuition we don't want those we want the
totals right okay so we kind of got rid
of that stuff
we don't need the state name so I'm
going to remove that when I state name
[Music]
because you have state code I'm gonna
say we are gonna filter out
we're going to filter out we're just
gonna kind of mess with the 4-year
degree even though people are getting
you know the two-year degree and stuff
like that but I think for this analysis
sake it's probably easier if we just do
that so we're just gonna do that and
we're going to deselect degree link to
okay and since room and board is
included within state and out of state
total we kind of don't need that those
are gonna be pretty correlated with each
other and that's gonna like violate some
assumptions for our linear model cuz
we're just gonna do a linear model we
could go crazy and do like something
like boosted model or some neural
network architecture but that really
doesn't make any sense for this but you
know we could just do something for the
sake of it being being fun so we might
do that you might do that so I guess
serve a state name and state so nobody's
have state code public-private yeah I'm
kind of into that obviously we're not
gonna use name we don't want it to like
overfit and just kind of memorize the
name but we'll kind of use that later
okay cool well let's say a model data
oops okay so with in-state and
out-of-state tuition I'm just gonna do a
basic plot where it's gonna be a GG plot
is x equals we don't really need to
figure out which one's gonna be react so
we just want to like plot out to see how
how correlated is okay so most of its
pretty similar but out of state tuition
is Alice when we loaded more I'm just
gonna do an average of it I think that's
kind of the go-to thing to do it so I'm
just gonna do like that yeah so I'm
gonna say tuition total equals in-state
total plus out of state total divided
room
let's see what that's yep we got it
should make sense and say yep technique
I could do a different function where
it's like I'm I could drop it but I'd
rather drop my own calms to be honest
okay
tuition tool and I kind of like having
tuition total at the beginning but we'll
just we'll just leave it there
also I notice we need to remove rank so
I'm gonna just do a select - rank okay
now here is something where we got to
think about something where we got to
think about our model do we really care
about stem percent do we think that's
necessary for our our model and like
what we're trying to accomplish so
here's here's me just thinking out loud
I kind of don't care this 10% because
I'm trying to look for a university that
has a great ROI who it's who's under
valued by my model and I don't really
care if my son or daughter does stem and
stem percent will be definitely biased
towards a high mid-career pay and we can
try it out figure it out if it's
actually true or not but you know just
from like understanding I guess their
domain knowledge of it it should be you
know correlated so let's do that all
right and then we'll do us select let's
just do is dot numeric select career
percent okay
and we'll just do a Gore thing okay
I stem percent early look at that
highest thing is correlated with is
early career and make her pay so I kind
of don't want to add it to it that's
just gonna be me I'm just gonna remove
it and I see with mid career early
career pay they're there they're highly
correlated and we kind of proved that
with both this right but I kind of still
want to add it to it even though
in there kind of making sense but we're
gonna just deselect the stem percent
sorry stem majors I'm sure you'll be
fine in the job market okay so we remove
that we got a model data keep in mind
we're not going to use this we don't
want to over fit it but we will use
state code type stuff like that and
we'll even add some interaction effects
and kind of feeling the interaction
effects so I'm gonna get broom out one
thing that I mean I'm gonna think about
is should should we actually do like
some data partitioning and just like
create a full-on model even though it
really isn't supposed to be used for
production it's more about a post
analysis on like understanding its
coefficients but we could we can I get
we can do it - all right so I'm gonna
actually install loading carrot which is
my machine learning package yep and then
we'll say create data create a partition
and then say model a tuition total P
equals we'll do a point eight a twenty
split this equals false let's call that
a trained index right so we did that and
we have a train in Excel basically like
random samplings okay and then we'll say
a train data equals a model data train
index Bop and then we'll say tests test
data model data and then we'll say -
train index okay so we have our train
and test sets we're just using carat to
partition it we don't really need it for
anything else but
okay and then was a test date okay so
now we're gonna train our linear model
okay so we'll say LM and we're gonna say
tuition tuition total Bob now we're
gonna add state state code state what
will state code plus ty plus early
career pay plus mid career fit bank plus
make world better percent data equals
train
data will that run okay
all right state code we're gonna make
sure name isn't in there okay and we're
actually to do uh tidy it and now we
kind of have our model okay and what
we're gonna start doing though is adding
some interaction effect so we know state
code x type probably has some effect
gonna be honest I think Asif have some
effect
so let's write their state code times
that public and stuff like that okay we
have our model we could just plot it out
and just do some model Diagnostics I
don't expect it to be great but it does
look not terrible
you know it's residuals are a little off
right on the lower and upper tiers but
it's residuals are it appears to be
normally distributed among scale
location right standardized residuals on
fitted values so it's not it's not a
terrible model maybe I could do a
summary too
mm okay
yeah I'm not terrible and then I'm
actually gonna have it predict on our
test data oh I was going on okay we'll
say a model base line model boom predict
base line model and then test huh what
the factor is has new levels envy oh
well so it has one of the factors so we
might have to drop a factor was kind of
weird cuz I thought we sampled it should
be doing it
face baseline model
where's envy yet interesting so yeah
does it is ignoring Nevada but he's not
good I'm actually just gonna do
something stupid and just we're just
gonna ignore that because I don't really
want to fit play with factors right now
so we're just gonna add model data to
that okay so now that we have our
baseline model on our entire dataset we
knew it we know it's fine it's whatever
we're just going to tune it we're gonna
awed meant it boom and what's its what
it's doing is it's saying like I'm we're
gonna try to predict tuition total and
here's the actual value what we should
be
so then we're gonna select tuition total
just to push it
after we're gonna we're gonna do
something we're gonna see mind our model
data data
school a select game right so now we
have our name and that makes sense right
is Adam state I just wanted to make sure
model Adam say it's Colorado yes okay so
now we have our name there and we can
just select I'm gonna clean this code up
a little bit but okay select name will
say tuition total and dot fitted okay
and we'll say actual equals and then
we'll say predicted right so now we have
an actual and predicted and what we're
trying to figure out and we can actually
do them all so we'll do a mid-career
mid-career okay
early career okay okay so now we have
our universities we have the actual cost
versus predicted cost with the mid and
early career pays oops what's
interesting with this is like our model
is using it knows your state it knows
the type of universities and it knows
that actually early in my career pays
and it's trying to evaluate like okay we
were trying to predict the actual cost
like we're saying like okay if we if we
have this college as a private college
in York New York and we know it gives
you like a sixty-five thousand
early career pay what's the cost what's
how much should tuition cost for that
call
right we built that model to basically
do that and now we're just trying to
find models or find find schools that
are actually below what the model is
predicted because the model saying yo
your uh your school you should be
charting this two ish this much tuition
and instead you're charging this little
of tuition so we're trying to find like
which mug which schools have a discount
so we're gonna have a discount or dot
pretty - actual and what this is saying
is saying like okay if your if our model
believes that your tuition should be 80
K and your actual tuition is 10 K then
you have a basic $70,000 coupon right
because what the education that you ship
you're getting is worth $80,000 where
you're actually paying 10,000 so that's
our discount oh it's not that pride it's
predicted predicted oh god what oh oops
that's why nice about this wrong actual
okay and now we're gonna do a top and or
n and eat for its top discount and n
equals we'll say the top ten schools
oops okay and then we'll just arranged
by discount deaths ending just cap okay
and look what look what we have here
Grove City College capital Technology
University Hudson University Brigham
always all these other universities that
aren't these like Ivy League schools
will do top 25 just to make sure look at
that
so all these universities are they're
saying like these are good universities
if you want to make some money then you
should be going to these things cuz like
if you don't have a lot of money then
you should think about it but so for
example Grove City College it cost
twenty seven thousand dollars to go
there but what they're saying is like oh
man it for that career pay you should be
paying like 52
UK and stuff like that so it's saying
like wow look at that mid career pays
98k and this 54 okay it's pretty huge
and we can kind of see how so these are
the these are the tops these are the top
colleges right but we can kind of like
just apply it to the entire model or
entire dataset and it's kind of Gigi
plotted out where it's like a s X equals
dot fitted y equals tuition total genome
point right
and then we'll say well I want to apply
that the actual thing and so GM point
plus Jim line a a es x equals I don't
know we'll say yeah
what am I looking out twitch elasticity
fit I'm trying to figure out if I want
to do something also and oh I bet I
could apply a gym what's here just let
me let me look it up apply linear linear
model and ggplot let's see if let's see
how I do this I'm pretty sure there's a
way to do this
oh okay we can do that okay so four to
five plus plus GM line forward it by
base line model without doing thing I'm
gonna do a okay data equals bump up oh
wait no what I'm time I'll just all
asleep like that okay and then we'll do
a plus GM smooth SC equals false method
equals Elam there we go that's how you
because I'm using I'm already using the
fitted so I know what it's gonna be
and then actually I'm gonna change it to
it Y and then X because it's what's
because I think I did is already but
we're saying the actual tuition total
should be right there and why is that
and where if if you're above the fitted
right on average don't fitted then
you're overpaying if you're below it
you're under paying so that's what
that's what we're trying to do and we
can actually show that let's say if we
want to do even right here we could
probably do a better one right but and
then we could say a ggplot AS x equals a
actual y equals predicted and we see a
color equals like discount GM
point all right I'm not sure if that's a
great thing actually I'm gonna do a next
year actual and then we'll say Y goes
discount plus Geum point and then now we
have kind of like which ones are
discount which ones actually you can see
how most of that ones with a higher
discount are always gonna be under price
right it's kind of a negative slope
going on very cool
okay well this is a pretty quick tie
Tuesday I really just wanted to use some
more models and kind of use the augment
functions so as we can see our most top
10 underrated colleges is Grove City
College Capital Tech University Husson
University Mount Carmel called your
nursing Brigham Young University of
Hawaii wah wah wah all those
universities congratulations I'm gonna
do one more thing just cuz I mean from
yours to Iowa what we're gonna do is
we're gonna look at university Iowa's
and hopefully it is correctly rated
filter name filter name equals
University of Iowa University of Iowa
actual predicted you know I'm a little
mad about that but I want to check Iowa
State University first you know Marissa
T I've seen University still a little
bit more overpriced but I'm fine with
that
University for a city of I off so my
model believes that you're in Iowa is a
little bit more overpriced than what it
actually is however I'm perfectly fine
with going here go Hawks
and I'll see you guys next week